i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from new york city tonight my
angle in moments but first
now whenever you find yourself looking
around at all the destruction he has
wrought wondering
how could things get worse than they are
under biden
well be sure to remember that his number
two is kamala harris so tonight
she sat down with dana bash in a much
ballyhooed first interview following the
dobbs decision at the court
but if you're expecting anything
profound from the former lawyer and
senate judiciary committee member
you came to the wrong interview
i was shocked and
you know it's one thing when you know
something's going to happen it's another
thing when it actually happens and i
just actually turned to cnn
and i couldn't believe it you know i
thought about it as you know a parent i
thought about it as a godparent of
teenagers
i thought of it as an aunt of of of
preschool children and a woman yourself
and a woman myself
and the daughter of a woman
and a granddaughter of a woman
it's a lot of repeating
at least she can identify a woman now
and if that word salad didn't do it for
you she also shared a big concern of
hers
that men won't be able to knock up girls
and then force them into abortions
first of all if you are a parent of sons
do think about what this means for the
life of your son
and what that will mean in terms of the
choices he will have
what
but the most important news to come out
of this interview came near the end
now tonight the new york times is out
with a story headlined
biden irked by democrats who won't take
yes for an answer on 2024
the piece noting that the white house is
trying to tamp down speculation about
plans for him to seek re-election while
aides say president biden
is bristling at the persistent questions
and for better or worse they trotted out
kamala to tamp down those rumors too
have you talked to president biden about
re-election joe biden is running for
re-election and i will be his ticket
mate
full stop close stop
that's it full stop as if republicans
needed any more good news these days you
just got it joining me now is charlie
hurt washington times opinion editor as
well as ben domenic a spectator editor
at large as well as the host of
overturning roe out right now on fox
nation now both of you are fox
contributors charlie let's start with
you now with biden abroad
we are getting a sneak peek right at
what the messaging from kamala uh kamala
led administration looks like it ain't
pretty
no it really is not and you're exactly
right just when you think it can't get
any worse
you know here's somebody who had spent
years on the senate judiciary committee
and
of course has underperformed at every
single
step of the way
but this is what you get when you have a
president who picks somebody based on
the color of their skin and their gender
and no other qualifications whatsoever
you wind up with this
ben what about the comment um about boys
how this is going to affect boys maybe
i'm i'm not getting what she meant but
it certainly sounded like boys are going
to have to be responsible more
responsible now i mean it was odd the
horror they're going to have to actually
take responsibility for their actions as
opposed to being able to you know pay a
girl to go away and have an abortion i
mean this is this is horrendous and it's
so disturbing but it's also so typical
the thing i love about kamala harris is
that she's too too dumb to really hide
any of the things that the left wants
you to hide about the positions they
actually have she just throws it out
there and then she kind of cackles
afterward and in this case this is
another example of it it's like oh my
gosh you're gonna have to tell your sons
that they're going to have to be
responsible if they go out and sleep
with someone and have a baby you know
and they're not just going to be able to
kill it and walk away isn't that
horrible and that's the sort of thing
that she would bring to any kind of
ticket in 2024 that she was the head of
the fact that she's uh you know emphatic
that she's going to be on this uh ticket
in 2024 i'm sure it totally encourages
all of those democrats who are concerned
about the moment don't worry everybody
they've got this thing under control p
buddha judge is watching that tonight
going i'm actually i can go on my bike
and i'm looking pretty good now on my
commuter bike all right charlie there
was something else we have to get to
beyond kamala which was this kind of
late breaking exchange that
came up around 6 30 or so tonight
between biden and macron today at the g7
where they're discussing
our reliance on the uae and biden's a
forthcoming trip to saudi arabia for oil
watch
increasing the prediction
you told me one i'm at the maximum
maximum
what he claims
and this is my
commitment second told me
according to us that
the saudis can increase a little bit but
150 or a little bit more and they don't
have huge capacities
at this before six months time
charlie i guess uh ron klein he has some
competition here what is this i mean he
was he briefing the president of the
united states on the fact that uh the
middle east is basically at max capacity
now and biden is like wow that he seems
to be really interested it's like
someone's giving me information i can
use what of that well
you know it's sort of hard to blame him
you know obviously uh hunter biden was
not available to be giving him all of
his expert advice on energy policy so
he's got to go somewhere for it but
honestly you know and this is no
different from the the the whole thing
with kamala harris this is joe biden's
chickens coming home to roost this is
what you get you have an administration
that is completely out of its depth on
energy policy they've done everything
they can they've
enacted war on energy independence in
america and this is what you wind up
with and you wind up with this this
horrifying spectacle and joe biden
returning to the middle east with hat in
hand begging for oil to to to
make life a little bit more livable in
the united states yeah but macron's
basically saying drill baby drill i mean
that's basically what he's saying there
the united states you're gonna have to
produce some oil um now ben i wanna play
something from cnn's um beloved
philosopher essie cupp about the future
of the gop watch
it's hard to imagine the republican
party surviving this
between anti-abortion
anti-lgbtq
book banning
anti-democracy i mean add all the
regressive
uh garbage sorry
to this
i don't take that back um
add it all together and i don't know
who's left in the future in future
generations to be drawn to this party
ben now the ap reported that we've added
uh the gop has added a million new
voters
uh so not sure what she's quite talking
about there but we'll have a lot of
people right because we're not i guess
they're not going to have as many
abortions and i guess a lot of people
think that's a good thing
laura i've known essie for personally
for more than a decade i consider her a
friend and i and i like her a lot i
disagree with her fundamentally on this
and i think she's completely wrong i
think in fact
the exchange that the gop has made here
in terms of moving more on the cultural
side towards this rising number of
hispanic immigrant diverse group of uh
voters who are you know not just brought
into the coalition of 2020 but i think
in the republican coalition going
forward on these culture war issues the
very issues she cites are a huge number
a much bigger number than the number of
uh suburban wealthy women who were going
to be you know pro-abortion you know
shout your abortion kind of voters who
are also going to be convinced to vote
for mitt romney i just don't think that
that was a long-term proposition that
would work in any way i think that the
autopsy that was done in 2012 was about
a party that was dead and this new
coalition this one that i think is far
more passionate that has a lot more
going for it and is about the american
family above all things you know is
something that actually represents a
long-term and very beneficial
development for the country a move away
from the harsh economic perspective of
the past and one that actually meets
families where they are and prioritizes
the issues as they see them as opposed
to the way that the new york times
editorial board believes they ought to
see them right and the gop establishment
will throw them in there as well charlie
and ben so great to see you tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else